hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute meine damen und
herren zu einem neuen video auf einem
kanal in dem ich mal wieder nicht
alleine bin sondern zusammen mit yu na
ja wir sind es bereits im titel und zwar
macht julia heute einen test ob sie mich
wirklich kennt denkst du schaffst das
ich glaube schon
deswegen bin ich auf die website texte
nicht gegangen und habe hier fünf tests
rausgesucht die in diesem jahr also 2019
über mich veröffentlicht wurden und
julia macht nun ist erste quiz namens
laser luca
also jule erste frage ist luca ein
youtuber wahr oder falsch
ich glaube das stimmt die zweite frage
luca hat keinen job das ist falsch weil
du hast einen shop und die ul ist es gut
gehen wird
bis jetzt 200 mal wenn ich mit jedem
video aufnehmen luca hat fünf milliarden
haben
das war allein das ist alles falsch ok
luca ist noch nicht 30 das ist auch wahr
das ist auch wahr weil die haben das
erste lied gemacht mit so gerne mit so
vermeiden fragen er hat keine freunde
das ist falsch da hat eine echte meine
freundin heißt sandra hallo sagen wir
nicht so gemeint das ist das ist ein
alptraum siebte frage luca hat einen
zweitnamen das stimmt doch herr thiele
die drittletzte frage sein zweiter name
ist till das ist frei ist es auch falsch
über der guard gesagt dass meine 200
kilo ist seine freundin hat auch einen
youtube-kanal stimmen
das stimmt hat auch einen kanal die
letzte frage seine freunde das eine
blondine
das ist es recht aber das ist wahr das
ist auch wahr was glaubst du punkte du
hast 10
ich glaub ich hab alles richtig doch
auch das zu zehn hast zehn punkte ja
also nicht zehn punkte durch einen punkt
von fünf bisher war allerdings direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten kürze meine
lieben freunde und zwar heißt es das von
crafter christ die erste frage lautet
wie heißt contractors schwester sarah
gebiet ag katja oder juli
das ist halt alles allein hat alles
falsch was man schreibt daran ohne h ja
aber du sagst dann ja sarah ok nächste
frage was hat luca in dubai gesehen
mauer taj mahal
burj khalifa katja krause wird oder
freiheitsstatue wieder als die dritte
frage lautet wie heißt sein zweiter
kanal luca luka konrad herkrath crafter
oder krohn crafter ich glaube dir heißt
luca war luca wird eigentlich auch
komplett in großbuchstaben geschrieben
viel zur frage wie heißt konkret dass
plüschhund nw labil und balu der bär
balu blut ja was ist konkret witzig oder
dumpf ich glaube ich nehm ich heiße
lernst du ja glaubst du dass es richtig
ich weiß es nicht da das sind halt
solche fragen kann nicht ja weißt du wie
ich weiß was hat contractor als erstes
fortnight item nachgebaut
oh mein gott ich habe ja sogar mit dabei
aber zack zack verband ziv judaslohn
gold ich glaub der was hat er als
letztes nachgebauten okay das ist letzte
woche habe ich das medi kit ich glaube
schon
was hat sich konkret tätowieren lassen
julien max contractor luca oder luxuriös
das ding ist ich habe mir einmal in
einem blog von henna tattoo machen
lassen also an tattoo was nicht immer
drauf ist dann für ein paar tage nur da
hast du mich sein wo soll ich das wissen
da kannten wir uns noch nicht auf wen
hat konkreter reagiert auf die bi
niemand hey moritz l mark oder katja
krawitz ich weiß nicht ob zwischen auf
die reagiert hat aber ich würde einfach
sagen katja ja also ich glaube auch dass
katar richtig ist und die letzte frage
wer ist konnte auf das lieblings youtube
in lisa und lena die bibi katja oder
domino kathi ich glaub es ist definitiv
cook tag und nach die videos ich fragte
sich auch hier wieder vorher was denkst
du was deine
punktzahl ist ich glaube ich habe sieben
punkte weil ich mir weil den 33 genau
hier klicken auf auswertungen 7
ja also kriegt jetzt ein punkt ein
das dritte kurs heißt wie gut kennst du
contractor luca die erste frage ist luke
eröffnete seinen kanal am erster august
2010 ist diese aussage wahr oder falsch
das ist halt das war auf jeden fall 2011
2011 ja okay die frage ist falsch wir
klicken auf nächste frage bisher hat
luca zwei bücher herausgebracht stand
februar 2009 10
ich weiß dass dieses gelbe buch und auf
jeden fall ein minecraft buch aber ich
weiß nicht ob du noch ein zweites
minecraft buch hast ich glaube es sind
drei bücher also falsch ja falsch dritte
frage zu seiner gegen gehört eine
ukulele einen hund aus nintendogs und
eine volcano flasche es ist doch ne
vitello flasche oder nicht es ist eine
flasche ja aber hat er das jetzt gerade
das verwechselt hat oder ob es
absichtlich falsch geschrieben hat
einfach mal war aber ich glaube der hat
es einfach verwechselt lukas
lieblingsfarbe ist blau fünfte frage
sein zweiter name lautet ilo war ja
hatten wir gerade schon sechs frage luca
war zweimal in new york stand ist
februar 2009 10 30.9 an luca liebt
alpakas war das war ich glaube dass
konnten uns alle selbst erklären
sein markenzeichen ist ein dreieck
falsche das ist auch falsch sein
markenzeichen ist ein smiley neunte und
vorletzte frage luca meine schwestern
und einen bruder ab auch falsch wer
kennt ja meine familie ich habe nur eine
schwester und zehnten flug rathaus
wurden zwei klubs stimmt also klicken
wir hier war ein und klicken jetzt mal
auf die auswertung und sowas acht von
zehn
ich habe erst zwei bücher herausgebracht
ja ich dachte du hast zwei so meinen 50
das heißt es bleibt leider bei einem von
fünf korrekt beantworteten tests das ist
das vierte quiz und zwar etwas kürzt
einfach laser luca und es ist ein quiz
oder contra vda im ersten von 15 fragen
lieblingsessen pizza quiche oder
spaghetti pizza pizza safe nächste frage
spitzname logo oder lucius von luxemburg
alles spitznamen aber ich würde das
verlöten
okay gut nächste frage wofür hat luca
früher sein ganzes geld ausgegeben für
computerspiele pizza oder pokémon karten
pokemon karten
das finde ich habe auch für
computerspiele eine menge geld
ausgegeben wird die frage sein
bürgerlicher name ist lukas reimann
lukas simon roberts oder luca timo
reimann luca thilo reimann ok nehmen wir
das nächste frage wann hat er geburtstag
21 februar 1996 dreiundzwanzigster juni
oder zwölfter oktober welches geräusch
hasst er knirschen styropor oder knochen
knacken
ich glaube ich sag styropor styropor
ja es ist glaube ich auch richtig hier
wir sind in der halbzeit ist christus
angekommen und zwar lieblingstiere
einpacker slums oder hunde
ich glaub das nächste frage welches
getränk bevorzugt er wasser kaffee oder
tee wasser
das sind aber alles auf einfache fragen
irgendwie was hasst luca wurst pilze
oder spinat pilze
das kann man ja alles so easy
beantworten welche farbe hatte di luca
pizza zwei sie war normal schwarz oder
pink lila schwarz
hey wir waschen hierdurch wie sonstwas
wo wurde er geboren köln bad hersfeld
oder bielefeld bielefeld
wie nennt er seine community löst yahoo
kader oder lucio lucio minister frage
wann er heftete er seinen kanal 28
februar 13 beiden seiten
august 2011 genre comedy musik local and
place comedy block oder als place comedy
beauty
das ist mittlere das hier ja ok und die
letzte frage meine lieben freunde wohl
lebt air berlin köln oder bielefeld
handys unsere beide richtig internet und
wo uns ja jetzt in kalkar ja ich wohne
in köln die auswertung meine damen und
herren du hast 13 von 15 aufgabe richtig
aber welche sind denn dann falsch das
ist das ist das waren wieder beantworten
da konnten mehrere richtig naja ich weiß
auch nicht aber es bleibt leider immer
noch bei 1 von 5 das letzte wisst dass
ich heute für julia ausgesucht habe
trägt den namen crafter ist der beste
youtube
das war ja zu lustig also harte
kontraste mehr abonnenten als gewinn
seit ich habe keine ahnung aber ich
glaub schon okay zweite frage von kraft
das vital flasche heiß wie tele und
nicht viel
das ist falsch ich glaube man schreibt
das mit v ist das richtig also das kann
ich jetzt schon mal sagen wann greift da
kommt aus bielefeld hatten wir jetzt
glaube ich oft genug also das ist auf
jeden fall war lukas schwester heißt
sarah der weiß ich hätte nicht ob es
eine fangfrage ist mir immer du weißt es
sie mit dass sie ohne h geschadet
von daher ich glaube ich glaube ich
glaube aber die denken einfach sarah
wird ein haus bauen also sollen wir
waren okay durfte frage luca hat ein
baby namens annabelle in echt falsch
falsch ich habe kein baby und sechste
frage jule ist in jedem video dabei die
frage wir sind gegen artikel 13 wie luca
ja das stimmt und die achte frage luca
geht im sommer nach bielefeld wegen dem
pool der eltern war das ist auch wahr
das ding ist ich will dir hierbei nicht
helfen aber die fragen sind teilweise so
eindeutig ja ich war leute frage luca
und max sind zusammen in vario vier
gestartet es war nie kreft projektor die
beiden letzten fragen ich habe keine
ahnung
die letzte frage ist luca ist in war of
fear folge fünf gestorben ich glaube du
meintest du bist dann auch schon am
anfang relativ deutlich sagt bei beiden
war ein war auf jeden fall zwei von fünf
quiz hast du richtig beantwortet julia
an der stelle wirklich einen daumen hoch
für dich für deine leistung danke ich
hoffe du fühlst dich jetzt schlauer und
kann es mir vielleicht an weihnachten
das ein oder andere bessere
personalisierte geschenke machen ja ich
denke jedoch auf jeden fall dein drittes
buch und alpakas bitten wir fertige
video auf jeden fall jetzt auch beenden
meine lieben freunde wenn euch das ganze
gefallen hat und eventuell auch mal ein
video folgt in dem ich schaue ob die
schule richtig kenne dann lasst seinen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier da
schreibt uns gerne in die kommentare
abonniert main kanal wenn ihr das video
nicht verpassen wollt und julia hat die
letzten sieben worte
[Musik]